how do you feel like Xbox is doing so
far as I start to 2016 we look at the
number of people that are playing on
xbox live when we look to success our
partners are having with their games on
our platform we look at what hat is
happening in first party it's really a
great time at xbox and I'd say the team
now really has a forward-looking vision
of what we want to where we want to take
gaming with Xbox including what we're
doing on Windows standing on console
it's nice to now to be able to
articulate that vision get reactions as
we always do when we announced news but
I think there's just a lot of energy in
the team and with our partners right now
which is a lot of fun and talking about
that integration with Windows 10 you had
a lot of comments about of the universal
system that you're putting together with
xbox and pc could you briefly describe
what with your vision is for them with
the universal Windows platform you have
these universal applications that can
run on multiple devices and we've said
from the beginning that you see games
now running on a breath of devices down
from phone to the highest end games at
4k 60 frames per second and thus for
windows and xbox developing a platform
that allows those game developers to
reach the largest audience of people
with the games that they want to deliver
is critical to both our long-term
success and of the ecosystem you did
mention that you don't like the
comparisons made two games for windows
live or those are comparisons that are
always going to be made no matter what
like those are things that are in the
past I don't know that it's I don't like
them I understand and like and we and
it's something we think a lot about when
we make commitments on things because i
think it's it's he and I'm not ducking
responsibility for games for windows
live but I wasn't in the role I'm in now
so you know I understand games for
windows live is part of the history of
Microsoft in gaming for PC gamers and we
absolutely have a responsibility to
answer the concerns of the people that
bet on us there and and the outcome and
its its front and center so it's it's
not i don't like the questions about it
I understand the skepticism that maybe
people create and I just want to be able
to stand up and say that we're very very
committed as a company to ensuring that
gaming on Windows is on Windows 10 as a
great
you think about something like our even
our launch promotion around quantum
break where if you buy it on xbox
pre-ordered on xbox you get the windows
10 version it gets really only possible
for us to kind of do the those kind of
programs when we're on both sides of the
transaction both the Xbox side and the
windows 10 side so us having our own
gaming store and the features around
that it's really about the features we
want to be able to bring to that
ecosystem but it's not to preclude
anybody else from from having success
there as well a hundred percent I view
valves success on windows as critical to
Windows success in gaming what about the
the xbox gamer for who wants to get into
virtual reality yeah it's a great
question and our bet on VR right now is
that an open platform for innovation
it's just the best place for something
that's this early in its incubation you
know we don't you can say minecraft will
be the killer app nobody's bought a copy
of Minecraft for VR yet right I mean
there's some mods out there and stuff
but we're still early in all of these
devices and taking that to a closed
ecosystem today I think it to me is just
too early doesn't mean that it doesn't
belong in console and I'm not saying
that others like I honestly I wish Sony
I hope sony has success with what
they're trying to do cuz I think it's
good for our industry as innovations
like VR take off but for me and where we
are with Xbox my bet is that putting the
development tools in the hands of
literally millions of people who can go
on Windows and start building their own
VR experiences is likely to lead to
faster content innovation than a closed
ecosystem would so we're supporting
valve we're supporting oculus we want to
make sure Windows 10 is a great place
for those developers that want to build
those early ideas around what might make
the killer app for VR so you've called
this the biggest year for her last year
you know was the biggest fear for xbox
and microsoft and of course now this is
the biggest biggest arrest biggest
tourister it is this are we going to
know if this is the biggest year yet for
Xbox or do we have to wait until e3 to
know if this overall 2016 is going to be
the biggest year for gaming the thing
that I see in 2016 for the industry is
the quality bar I don't think has ever
been higher when you look at games that
coming out and that
ideas that people trying to push we have
more indie developers and we've ever
seen on our platform trying to do some
of the craziest thing with games which I
love right at so I think 2016 will be a
continuation of I'm not I don't know if
I say the greatest game is excellent
else am i right sit on a slide somewhere
but you know I think about more just the
health of the industry and the health of
the platform I've got more people
playing on live playing more games than
we've ever seen Sony's having great
success it sounds like Nintendo is going
to have a very cool announcement at e3 I
don't know anything about it but it
sounds like it sounds like just yet
another great year for gaming across so
many different devices which is
fantastic